no one cared about my opinion when I was
a little kid no one cared what I thought
sometimes people would say what do you
think you're doing but that just meant
stop they didn't actually want to know
my thought process they don't want me to
be like well I was gonna put this bottle
rocket into this Cardon of eggs so that
when I lit off the bottle rocket the
eggs would have bloat everywhere oh well
that's very interesting and what brought
you to this experiment oh well thank you
for asking well you know how I'm filled
with rage I'm so horny and angry all the
time and I have no outlet for it so eggs
like I travel alone sometimes you know
and I'll put up with anything you know
like I'll book a ticket on some garbage
airline you know I don't want to name an
actual airline so let's just make one up
let's call it like Delta Airlines so I
booked a ticket on Delta Airlines and
I'll show up at the airport then I go
can I get on the plane now please and
they go now
it's delayed nine hours
and I go okay and then I go to the
bathroom and then I come out of the
bathroom and I go any updates and they
go yeah we took off while you were in
the bathroom because we hate you I take
this meal voucher that doesn't work go
fetch and I go okay and I go over to the
Wolfgang Puck Express and I go can I
have a sandwich please and they go no
then I go okay and they go you're a
little fat girl aren't you
and I go no when they go say it and I go
I'm a little fat girl and then I go over
to the Delta helpdesk which is an
oxymoron and I go can I please go home
on an airplane and they go no in fact
we're gonna frame you for murder and
you're gonna go to jail for 30 years and
I go why are you doing this to me
and they go because we're Delta Airlines
and life is a [ __ ] nightmare
but with my girlfriend she would just be
like let's see if Southwest has any
flights so it's better my email got
hacked a few weeks ago but it was kind
of cool it was that it was the thing
where they hack into your email has just
happened the hack in and then they send
like a weird spam link to everyone in
your address book so I basically sent a
spam link to everyone I know
which was kind of nice cuz I don't keep
in touch with people so that's my bit
for the year that is my Christmas card
as far as I'm concerned
and then everyone wrote back to me to
tell me I've been hacked so I heard from
everybody it was nice it was like I had
a baby or something
email viruses bring people together in
amazing waves one guy I know emailed me
and he said hey I clicked on the link
you sent I don't want to buy any herbal
viagra and he wasn't being funny I've
known him for 17 years it's not a funny
person he's an idiot so what I liked
about that was a few things one he
clicked on the link who the hell still
clicks on the link when you get the spam
link and this by the way this was the
ugliest internet link I've ever seen in
my life
it had like dollar signs and swastikas
in it
it looked like a virus I don't mean an
Internet virus I mean it looked like if
HPV was a website written out he got
that in a blank email and he went okay
and he clicked on it he was intrigued
and then he has taken to a website that
sells something called herbal viagra and
his first thought is that I am now
selling herbal viagra but do you know
what kind of offended me it was that he
thought that that's how I would sell
herbal viagra that I would be that
pissed poor of a Salesman that I would
just put a link in a blank email with
the subject line check this out which
I've never said before in my life and
then in the two column I'd write
everybody and I got this speaks for
itself if I was going to email everyone
I've ever met about a very shaky new
business I was involved in I would write
a long like introduction letter before I
got to the link I would be like dear
friends and family comedy did not work
out also have you ever wanted to try
viagra but you fear the side-effects of
the non herbal kind
well me and my Cayman Island business
partners have the solution for you just
click on the swastika below and in
seconds you'll be taken to the world's
ugliest website I hope you can read pink
on purple as that is the layout we have
chosen
Oh see thank you I didn't pause for that
but that's nice I paused for that that's
why I paused I was walking downtown
today I was on West 12th Street I was
downtown I was walking towards this guy
he's walking towards me he's on his cell
phone
we're both downtown we're on West 12th
as he walks past me I hear him say not
and I can't meet right now I'm Way
uptown and then he looked at me and he
winked and he kept walking that guy
should be declared mayor of New York
City I don't care if he's had a scandal
automatic mayor and he probably has if
that's how he conducts himself on a day
to day basis if he's lying about his
whereabouts at 2:00 o'clock on a
Saturday while I high-fiving random guys
on the street I was glad I noticed him I
normally don't notice people Izone out
constantly have you ever shown doubt for
a few minutes I've been zoned out since
2014 I just all day long I wander into
traffic walking like Charlie Chaplin
listening to a podcast while thinking
about a different podcast I can zone out
anywhere I was at the doctor's office he
was reading me the results of a blood
test it was important I listened and I
zoned out I was like nah I'm gonna stare
at the wall and think my thoughts I was
like huh none of the Beatles had
mustaches but then one day all of them
had mustaches that's weird I can't think
of a time a group has done that some
people in my life don't want me to zone
out as much they want me to focus and
they want me to be in the moment and
they want me to do this by meditating I
don't know if you've ever tried
meditating but I've been trying it this
is how you meditate okay you sit on the
floor with your back perfectly straight
which I hate more than Isis and then you
take deep breath I don't like sitting up
straight all right it's never gonna
happen if meditating was sitting hunched
over on the toilet with your elbow on
your knee while kind of looking at your
phone I'd be the Dali Lama
I don't like sitting up straight so you
sit up straight and you breathe and this
helps you stay in the moment don't
bother the moment is mediocre at best
yeah I mean it's fine let's all try
right now let's all be in the moment in
silence right now sucked right not fun
at all that was boring
you got a zone out you have an
imagination you have a movie theater in
your brain that plays fake arguments
that you win have you ever just been
sitting there thinking about something
for like 2025 minutes and all of a
sudden you're like oh my god I'm driving
and you remember yeah I'm going 75 miles
an hour I have been for a while I could
have changed so many lives sometimes my
wife I have this wife she'll be like are
you watching the road and I'm always
like I am looking through the windshield
and I'm not gonna hit anyone but no I'm
thinking about the Beatles for years I
was a child and during that time I went
to a school right but I was terrible in
school I was awful at it my worst
subject was math and in the grade school
that I went to they did this thing one
year where they divided all the kids up
into two different math groups right
based on your abilities and the first
group that you could be in was called
the Blue Angels and it was named after
the famous aviators and the other group
was called group - yeah
oh we were a swell bunch of kids in
group - best part of it is we picked the
name ourselves the teacher was like what
are we gonna call you group - and we
were like a bingo you got it right there
or in five is 12 - anxious for a lot of
things I get very nervous all the time
not even about like major life things
just like about in everyday situations
like this is my regular speaking voice
but if I'm in a public bathroom and
someone knocks - suddenly on the stall
door I go into a whole different
speaking voice which is someone's in
here someone's in here so if they're
gonna be like I think there's a carnival
barker in there I think someone's trying
to drum up business for a carnival I
decided to do something about all this
anxiety recently I decided I was gonna
try and get a xanax prescription I don't
know if anyone here has ever tried xanax
but it's fantastic very muted claps for
xanax you don't really get rused it's
more like yeah I didn't know how to get
his an ex prescription no drugs like
that a tricky sometimes but I talked to
a friend of mine and he said hey I did
this he said that he had a regular
doctor's appointment and at the end of
it he said to his doctor hey doctor
sometimes I get nervous on airplanes and
the doctor just wrote him a xanax
prescription and I was like yeah that's
the type of low brow I'm looking for
I'll take your advice friend I've never
listened to before so I go to a clinic
and I go in and I'm just gonna go in for
you know a regular type of checkup and
at the end I'll ask about xanax so I get
to the front desk and they have a why
are you here sheet and I want to pick
something that will get me in and out
really quickly and I look down and I see
frequent urination and I was like
perfect that'll be a super quick visit
you know I'll just be like hey sometimes
I pee a lot and the doctor will be like
me too crazy right
and I'll be like I get nervous on
airplanes so I checked off frequent
urination and I sat down in the waiting
area and I waited for three hours I
finally go back to the observation room
and oh in the observation room there is
a male nurse
standing there and he has a Batman
sticker on his stethoscope a Batman
necklace and a Batman watch he was kind
of moving around the whole time you know
he was just like alright I am too
blessed to be stressed let's do it what
are you allergic to besides work and
then he takes something and he throw it
over his shoulder and be like beats
working like all of his jokes were very
anti work which is not always what you
want from a healthcare professional the
doctor comes in the room and the doctor
looks at my chart and he says oh you're
here for frequent urination how many
times a day are you urinating and I
tried to think of a number that would
warrant a doctor visit so I said eleven
and that was too many times to say the
doctor looks at me says you're being 11
times a day then you may have something
wrong with your prostate so what we need
to do some of you are ahead of me so I
don't know exactly how he phrased it but
the gist of it was hey if this visit is
to continue I'm going to stick part of
my hand up your ass and I didn't know
what to say cuz I couldn't be like no
that's okay
I was lying
it was a lie to get drugs you know like
a crime so what I did was I pulled down
my pants and I walked over to the
observation table and I put my hands
down on the observation table like this
and by the way part of me was like
whatever you know you know those days
when you're like this might as well
happen adult life is already so goddamn
weird
so I'm bent over like this on the table
and the doctor comes up behind me goes
no no no not on your hands on your
elbows and he knocks me down like that
and this is so much worse than this I
don't know why I think it's that this
has like a little remaining dignity to
it you know what I mean this is sort of
like go stick it in I am an American
this is like you're leaning over the
edge of a cruise ship and you're like ah
we are approaching Martinique
we knocked me down to my elbows and then
he stuck his hand in and you know how
sometimes you're like I bet I know what
most things feel like you know you just
big deal no I did not know what this was
gonna feel like and this was the actual
sound I made I went but I didn't say it
like it came from my vocal cords but it
was totally involuntary It was as if a
ghost had been trapped in my belly and
finally flew out towards the light and
then when he pulled his hand out we've
gotten to know each other pretty well so
I will phrase this as delicately as I
can I did not realize that when the
doctor pulls his hand out it feels like
you cause the only thing that's ever
come out of your butt before has been he
pulls his hand out and I thought that I
was into his hand so I yelled I'm sorry
[Applause]
this is a very routine procedure by the
way for most doctors and so far he's had
to deal with oh I'm sorry
and he didn't even let me off the hook
you know he wasn't like I don't worry
you didn't into my hand he just threw
his glove away and was like yeah
and that's about to ask about xanax but
then he said all right your prostates
fine but we still need to do a blood
test so I pulled up my pants and
shuffled away feeling different and he
yells out into the hall he goes hey
we're doing a blood test get in here and
Batman dances back in and he's like all
right we're gonna do a blood test
you look different let's do it the
doctor left the room so I'm alone with
Batman I just need this blood test to be
over okay but first I had to tell Batman
saying I said Batman look I'm one of
those people who when you take blood
from me sometimes I can faint and I was
in the waiting area for three hours and
I haven't eaten all day and I'm really
worried I'm gonna faint
and Batman said to me and I'll never
forget it Shh you're not gonna faint so
I stick my arm out Batman puts the
needle in I immediately collapse on the
ground I wake up and I am covered in
sweat lying on the observation table I
wake up I opened my eyes and I see
Batman's face he's looking at me he goes
you got a go and I said can I please
talk to the doctors no first because
sometimes I get nervous on airplanes
and Batman said the doctors gone so I
got my stuff and I left the moral of the
story is that if you've been nervous
your entire life you should ask your
doctor about xanax because if you lied
to him he will stick his finger in your
ass and if you do suffer from frequent
urination keep it to yourself I went to
that clinic two years later for a
different checkup and as I was leaving
who did I run into but Batman and he
smiled at me and he was wearing reading
glasses to show that time had passed I
watched too much crime stuff I do too
many crime dramas I love law and order
that is my favorite show on television I
love it's good I love love order because
it's the same episode every single time
like it's the same thing again and again
law and order is to the point that like
you see the same types of characters on
every law and order some of my personal
favorites there is a guy who while being
questioned by homicide detectives will
not stop unloading crates
doesn't matter to this guy double rape
and murder nah he's gotta unload that
van the detectives will show up with all
these serious questions and this guy is
just like Tony Ramirez yeah I remember
him used to work here Tuesdays right
it's like dude people have died how
often are you questioned by homicide
detectives
I love law and order and I miss Jerry
Orbach more than certain dead relatives
of mine he was the best he was the best
for those of you that don't know who
that is Jerry Orbach he was a wonderful
actor he played detective Lennie Briscoe
on Law & Order for many many years he
was also the dad and Dirty Dancing he's
the one that put Baby in the corner
that's right he was a wonderful actor
but a couple years ago he died now you
may know that you may not know and I not
lying to you Montreal I wouldn't do that
after Jerry Orbach died this is
absolutely true he donated his eyes to
the New York Eye Bank
he was an eye donor so there's these
signs all around New York that say Jerry
Orbach gave his heart and soul to the
gift of acting and the gift of sight to
two New Yorkers to New Yorkers got Jerry
ohrbach's
eyes sorry like as a transplant not just
to have like they got them put it
two different New Yorkers though that is
fascinating to me because they're two
different New Yorkers they probably
don't know each other right
they're probably strangers well that
would make a great movie would make a
great romantic comedy oh I can see the
preview now they're just like he's an
average guy who only likes sports
dude you sold your grandmother's wedding
ring what it was for season tickets
she's a busy businesswoman who only
likes business ma'am could you turn off
that Bluetooth we're at a baptism
he's March Madness she's Merrill Lynch
got it but they have one thing in common
they both have Jerry or box eyeballs
shoved into their face New Line Cinema
presents love at first sight
this summer love is spelled with two
eyes and the scene I thought a lot about
it thank you and the scene where the two
where the guy and the girl finally find
each other because the first act of the
movie they get the eye transplant that's
a given rest of the movie they're
walking around New York but they keep
like criss crossing paths like in that
movie serendipity which is not bad so
they're walking around you're like oh
when are they finally gonna meet and
here's the scene where they meet okay
cuz if you remember on Law & Order
whenever Jerry Orbach saw a dead body
he'd make a funny little joke he'd make
a one-liner every single time so the guy
in the girl are coming down the street
from opposite ends of the street alright
and there's an alley in the middle of
the street and there's a teacher lying
dead in the alley and at the same moment
they both go school's out and then they
lock eyes it's wrong to make fun of
people you know but it's so fun
sometimes I've written for some TV shows
and you know on a major TV show you have
to be careful about what you say about
people cuz a lot of people could get
offended or so it has been explained to
me I was once I'll tell you this I was
writing for an awards show once and I
got into some trouble I wrote a joke for
this award show that had the word [ __ ]
in it and someone from the network came
down to our offices and he said to me
hey you can't put the word [ __ ]
on TV and I said I sure would like to
and he said no [ __ ] is as bad as the
n-word first off no no it's not do you
know how I know it's not I said to him
is because we're saying the word [ __ ]
and we're not even saying what the N
word is
if you're comparing the badness of two
words and you won't even say one of them
that's the worst word I turned 30
recently I watched movies very
differently because you understand for
years and years I was a child and when I
would watch an action movie I would
identify with the action hero who's
trying to help people now when I watch
an action movie
I only identify with like the side
characters who are often the corner
rolling their eyes you know the ones
that I like spider-man like those types
that's how I'd feel if I heard about a
spider-man you know was my fav you knows
my favorite action hero when I was a kid
was Michael J Fox is Marty McFly in Back
to the Future that was when he was my
hero
I loved Marty McFly he's great right I
wanted to be like him in every way I
watched that movie again recently Marty
McFly is a 17 year old high school
student whose best friend is a disgraced
nuclear physicist and I [ __ ] you not
they never explained how they became
friends and we were all fine with it
we never even asked you know that we
were just like who's his best friend a
disgraced nuclear physicist okay yeah
pursued yeah no no just good proceed
with the movie I know back to the future
is a great movie in a hit movie it's a
very weird movie I just watched it again
it has a lot of weird things in it two
guys had to go in and sell that movie
two guys had to go into a movie studio
and be like okay so we have an idea for
the next huge family action movie and
it's about a guy named Marty and he's a
he's a high school student and he's very
lazy he's always sleeping late they're
like okay okay is he is he cool like
Ferris Bueller now but he has a best
friend yeah you know who's a you know a
disgraced nuclear physicist
I'm sorry I'm confused this is this is
another student or oh no no no no no
this other guy's either like 40 or 80
even even we don't know how old he's
supposed to be anyway
so one so one day the boy and the
scientist they build a time machine whoa
okay okay I think I see where this is
going now let me guess they they build a
time machine and they go back in time
and they stop the Kennedy assassination
ah no no is a really good idea yeah we
didn't even think of that
okay well what do they do with the time
machine well now I am embarrassed to say
all right all right here goes nothing
we thought we thought you know that it
would be fun for people if the boy you
know he went back in time and he tried
to [ __ ] his mom we just we thought that
that would be fun and then oh yeah no
but no but don't worry he doesn't he
doesn't get to [ __ ] the mom because this
family friend named Biff shows up and he
tries to rape the mom you know in front
of the Sun and then the dad he has to
beat the rapist off of her and we're
also gonna say that a white man wrote
Johnny be good so we're gonna take that
away from them well this sounds like a
fantastic movie we are definitely gonna
make this now you say that they go to
the past do you want to call it back to
the past nine I now back to the future
right but they go to the past yeah I
don't mean to complain about censorship
at all though because as you probably
have seen by now you can basically say
whatever you want on television it's
ridiculous you can say anything you want
and if you don't believe me you should
watch a little program called Law &
Order Special Victims Unit
yeah a show that I love because on that
show you can say the grossest things
you've ever heard in your life no you
can't say like the f-word you can't say
that on Special Victims Unit
but people walk around on SVU going like
looks like the victim had anal
contusions looks like we found semen and
fecal matter in the victims ear canal
those are two real things that I heard
on Law & Order SVU at 3:00 in the
afternoon both spoken by ice-t
I stink is a detective with the Special
Victims Unit he handles New York's most
sensitive cases
I love ice-t on SVU he is fantastic he's
awesome what's so great about him is
that he's been with the SVU for like 11
years now but he still treats every case
like it's his first in terms of total
confusion sometimes no be in the middle
of an investigation
and ice-t would be like yo you telling
me this dude gets off on little girls
with pigtails
like yes he's a pedophile
you work in the Sex Crimes Division
you're gonna have to get used to that
you know how they try and tie in like
current events to every episode SVU so
there's there was this episode I saw a
while ago that was about sex addiction
because a lot of celebrities had come
out as sex addicts
so the episodes about sex addiction
there is a scene in the episode where
the other detectives are trying to teach
ice-t what sex addiction is and it takes
a couple of minutes and finally ice-t
gets it and they cut to him in this
close-up and he goes oh I get it
you mean like when someone drinks too
much horse snorts cocaine or bets the
house on the ponies I was like yeah you
got it man and I was psyched that ice-t
understood so that they could continue
with the investigation but I could have
watched another four hours of ice-t just
naming examples just that close up an
iced tea like or like when someone
smokes too many cigarettes or like when
someone shops too much for credit cards
or like when someone plays too many
Scratchy lotteries
or like when someone eats too much
chocolate cake or like when someone eats
too much chocolate cake and then barf
setup and he would just keep talking and
it would slowly fade out and say
executive producer Dick Wolf
that'd be my ideal episode that'd be a
good name I also watched the show called
cold-case files on cold-case files they
solve old murders and it's really
interesting because what I learned from
it is that it was really easy to get
away with murder before they knew about
DNA it was ridiculously easy like what
was even going on back then what was a
murder investigation like in 1935 one
cop would just walk in and be like
detective
we found a pool of the killer's blood in
that hallway you just be like mmm gross
now then back to my hunch
look for clues I'll tell you what we'll
do
well the trot shock around where the
body is that way we'll know where it was
a couple years ago I saw this movie
called Public Enemies with Johnny Depp
was about old bank robbers and stuff
here's how easy it was to get away with
bank robbery back in the 30s as long as
you weren't still there when the police
arrived you had a 99 percent chance of
getting away with it to the point that
like those old bank robbers they take
credit for the bank robberies like they
come running out of there and they're
like ha ha ha and if anyone asks you
tell them it was gold and Joe with the
seconds gang and then they like shoots
uh guns into the side of the wall like
what we're bullets free back then and
they don't even disguise themselves they
dress up for the bank robbery they're
rolling in there in like big suits and
hats like they're going to church in
Atlanta they make a day of it talk to a
lot of people before I got engaged you
know and I heard this expression about
whether or not you should get married
this is an old expression people say
this they say why buy the cow when you
can get the milk for free you ever heard
that before
it's a bananas insulting expression to
an entire gender but also it makes no
sense why buy the cow when you can get
the milk for free you're not allowed to
milk a cow that you don't own
that's not even a situation
was that a problem at one point like in
the dairy community was that happening
like a hundred years ago in some village
some Dutch prick was sneaking in at
night being like I take your milk and
the farmer was like one of them this is
your cow now and he was like no no proof
of purchase and he ran off into the
night that sounded Dutch right you know
what that you know what that expression
means it means why would you marry a
woman if she's already having sex with
you which has nothing to do with what
relationships are even like anymore now
it's like why buy the cow question mark
maybe because every day the Kyle asks
you when you're gonna buy it
you live in a really small apartment
with the cow so you can't avoid that
question at all and also the cow is way
better at arguing than you are and the
cow grew up in a family that knows how
to argue why buy the cow question mark
maybe because every time another cow
gets bought you have to go to the sale
and you have to sit next to your cow at
the sale and your cow looks over at you
the entire time like
and does not enjoy the sale at all even
though she's the lung I wanted to go to
the sale
and she's especially mad because that
farmer and cow met like eight months
after you guys met why buy the cow well
let's be real here you're very lucky to
have the cow that you do have their
roping in cows and getting milk out of
them was never anything you were known
for John by the most liberal of
estimates there have been about eight
cows total several um milked and a lot
of people think that you like Bulls and
if you just thought they assumed it when
you search your name the third thing to
come up is like john mulaney bull
question mark and if you just bought the
cow nobody would say that any more
they'll still say it because there are
those guys who they buy a cow and then
on the side total Matador but but for
real Chicago why buy the cow let's be
real why buy the cow because you love
her
you really do and yeah yeah sure she's a
bossy little Kubik
she takes care of you and you don't want
to be some old man stumbling around like
hey you seen any loose milk